et retour en france avec les suites du
procès des attentats de janvier 2015 à
paris à montrouge
ce matin mohamed fares a été interrogé
il aurait pu apporter un soutien
logistique aux terroristes ont fait le
point justement avec notre reporter
katia technique à la cour d'assises
spéciale de paris l'audition du jour
doit permettre d'y voir plus clair sur
la filière des armes qui ont servi à
midi coulibaly aujourd'hui est entendue
mohamed fares et un trafiquant de drogue
qui est suspecté pour ce procès-là
d'être aussi trafiquants d'armes
or mohamed fares ni alors pour mieux
comprendre comment tout cela s'est passé
il ya à l'origine un trafiquant d'armes
lillois claude hermant qui est aussi
indiquée identitaire il se trouve qu'il
n'est pas inculpé dans ce dossier et en
bout de chaîne il ya bien sûr
amedi coulibaly le terroriste l'hyper
cacher mohamed farès qui est connu pour
être un trafiquant de drogue aurait
peut-être intercepté des armes et
peut-être transmis ses armes à hamar
ramdani essaye de makhlouf deux autres
accusés ces deux accusés ont été
entendus ils expliquent qu'ils sont
bienvenues dans le nord mais pour
discuter avec mohamed fares de trafic de
drogue alors à ce propos je vous propose
d'écouter l'avocate des parties civiles
quatre ims marques comme vous le savez
il nous manque quand même des personnes
pour mettre la filière d'armes en place
certaines personnes ont déjà été
condamné par une juridiction lilloise
mais
et du coup la filière enfin le du début
à la fin on n'aura pas nécessairement
donc on essaie d'avoir au moins les
derniers les derniers passages des armes
pour qu'ils arrivent enfin dans les
mains de coulibaly mohamed fares vous
permet-il de mieux comprendre comment
s'est déroulé le trafic d'armes et bien
pour le moment
il dit qu'il n'est pas du tout mêlé à
cela que lui le trafic de drogue il
suffisait amplement qu'il estime
simplement